- Oh, another animal hater.
(laughing)
- [Woman] We're gonna look
at some of your films,
and we're gonna see what
critics said about them,
and then you try and
guess which film it is.
- I, who normally don't
like Kevin Hart at all,
was so impressed with his dramatic chops,
that I am going to recommend.
- I mean what kind of complement
and insult at the same time
is that, he's talking about The Upside.
(bell dings)
- He's talking about The Upside, yeah.
- I normally don't like
Kevin Hart, you know what,
you guys got some nerve.
How you make a napkin dance?
Put a little boogie in it.
Look, look.
The movie is stupid, dumb, and ridiculous,
but the end bring it home in
a way that actually might be
a good time, only if you're drunk.
- Wow.
Stupid, fun, and ridiculous,
but it might be a good time,
if you're drunk.
(laughing)
Got 'em.
Baywatch.
(buzzer sounds)
(laughing)
- Bath time shithead.
- Rampage, Rampage.
- Oh, another animal hater.
Another animal hater,
whoever you are, oh my God.
Son of a bitch!
Tolerable.
So just tolerable, that's it,
that's all you get, is tolerable.
- [Kevin] That's all I get for the movie?
- Which this movie was
73% Certified Fresh.
- Okay, tolerable, Pets,
Secret Life of Pets?
(bell dings)
- Secret Life of Pets, baby.
- Advantage me!
(laughing)
Uh oh.
It's great fun, and nowhere
near as annoying as a cast
including Jack Black and
Kevin Hart should be.
(laughing)
- Oh my God, you guys, hi.
- Wow.
Jumanji, I'm assuming.
(bell dings)
- Yeah that's what was it, yeah.
- Really?
I'm a nerd!
Destined for heavy rotation on TNT
to be half-watched for a
few minutes at a time by
channel-surfers and laundry-folders.
- Well that could be any one of my movies.
(laughing)
Think Like a Man 2?
(buzzer sounds)
- There is a two.
- Ride Along 2.
- It's Ride Along 2.
- He called it a TNT special.
- I got his name, I got his name.
- Do you got him?
(yelling)
(crash)
- God dammit--
- If you were suffering from Brexit blues,
then watching a tiny
comic repeatedly clocking
a hulking muscle man
around the chops could be
just what the doctor ordered.
- Central Intelligence.
(bell dings)
- There you go.
- Come on.
- One of my few good
scores on Rotten Tomatoes.
(singing)
- Stoners will enjoy,
everyone else should stay home
and watch "Chappelle's Show",
but stoners will enjoy this movie.
- Well, this is, I mean--
- One we reference often.
- Oh, Soul Plane.
- Soul Plane.
- Blah, I almost got a little
spit on you, I'm sorry.
Not so much a story as The
Rock's upper body workout
with explosions cgi'd behind him.
- Give me the date.
- 2018.
- Rampage?
(buzzer sounds)
- Nope.
- Skyscraper, yes.
(bell dings)
Got any duct tape?
- By the way, I can tell
that a lot of these people
tuck their sweaters in.
That's just a fact.
(upbeat music)